Oliver Kater sitzt heute bei uns und wir
wollen sprechen über dieses gerade diese
Gerüchte die seit langer Zeit gibt seit
fast seit Beginn dieses Krieges das
offenbar die Russen dabei sind
systematisch ukrainische Kinder zu
verschleppen und wenn man mit Leuten
spricht die sich damit auskennen sagen
die alle auch Putin hat diesen
demografischen Faktor im Hinterkopf da
geht es in diesem Krieg nicht nur
unbedingt um um territoriale Gewinne um
Land Gewinne sondern es geht darum die
eigene schrumpfende Bevölkerung wieder
größer zu machen es geht darum junge
Menschen ins Land zu holen und das macht
man zum Teil auf unglaublich perfide Art
und Weise
sie sagen das gibt es das findet statt
und sagen geschätzt ungefähr 16.000
Kinder sind bereits verschleppt worden
und sagen es gibt drei Methoden nachdem
das läuft drei ganz konkrete Abläufe
welche sind das vorkommt zum einen waren
das Kinder die in Ferienlager waren in
Gebieten die dann unter Besatzung
gerieten also tatsächlich Kinder die die
eigentlich dort Urlaub machen wollten
und dann ohne ihre Eltern in diesen
jetzt besetzten Gebieten waren und die
wurden dann eben auch verschleppt dann
werden Kinder verschleppt von Eltern die
in diesen besetzten Gebieten jetzt
besetzen Gebieten und auch damals
besitzen Gebieten ermordet wurden oder
starben aufgrund der Angriffe und dann
auf einmal sozusagen weisen waren Kinder
auch die
die ihre Eltern einfach verloren haben
weil es Chaos gab und die die dann nicht
gesehen haben
und es kommt auch dazu dass zum Beispiel
weisenhäuser ganze weisenhäuser oder
Grundschulen die beide Ankunft der
russischen Streitkräfte vor Ort da
gerade zusammen waren also dass das
diese Kinder dann aus diesen staatlichen
Institutionen
wurden die werden mitgenommen und dann
Militärflugzeugen und dann bis nach
Moskau teilweise gefahren es gibt 43
Ferienlager sogenannte Ferienlager im
Ganzen in ganz Russland und die werden
dann im ganzen Land verteilt und
teilweise ist es wirklich weit im Osten
also wirklich ganz weit weg von Ukraine
was ist schwierig gemacht für die Eltern
die überhaupt noch mal zurückzubekommen
damit man sich das mal klar macht da
geht ein sechs siebenjähriger morgens
aus dem Haus geht in seine Schule die
eigentlich ein geschützter Raum ist den
erkennt diesen Raum den er auch liebt da
sind seine Freunde und plötzlich kommt
ein russischer Soldat durch die Tür und
sagt ich nehme jetzt mit die meisten
dieser Kinder wurden bei Ankunft der
russischen Streitkräfte mitgenommen also
so wie man das sich vorstellen kann gab
die Offensive die Kinder haben sich
versteckt und wurden dann wurden dann
gefunden dort von russischen
Streitkräften die ankam und würden dann
mitgenommen ja warum
es gibt mehrere Faktoren zum einen ist
es natürlich der propaganda-faktor für
die eigene Gesellschaft wir sehen dass
diese Kinder sehr gerne hergezeigt
werden im Propaganda Videos auf
verschiedenen Kanälen man sagt dann
diese armen armen Kinder wir helfen den
jetzt wir schützen die jetzt wir sind
die guten und wer wer möchte vielleicht
in Russland ein solches Kind aufnehmen
also das ist dass wir wir machen nicht
nur Schlechtes sondern wir machen hier
eigentlich was ganz gutes was ihr
wirklich boshaft ist es ist wirklich
großartig denn man spielt dann man
spielt so eine parallel Wirklichkeit vor
in der vielleicht sogar die Ukraine
dafür verantwortlich sind dass es diesen
Kindern so schlecht geht und dass sie
Leid erfahren haben das zum einen
natürlich ist es aber auch
psychologische Kriegsführung das ist ich
meine man kann sich nichts schlimmes
vorstellen als dass die eigenen Kinder
entführt werden und das ist für die
Ukraine auf die ukrainischen Familien
sehr sehr dramatisch
wenn sie sagen die Propaganda spielt ja
aber eine ganz zentrale Rolle eine auch
entscheidende Rolle spielt eine Frau in
diesem ganzen Gefüge wer ist das Maria
Lover
genannte
kinderrechtsbeauftragte seit Oktober
2021 die sich eben darum kümmert um die
Umverteilung dieser Kinder um die auch
Entführung dieser Kinder beide die
wieder sehen mittlerweile gesucht per
internationalem Haftbefehl ganz genau
vermutlich auch zum Teil wegen dieses
Videos dass im Februar 2023
gezeigt wurde das ist ein es wurde im
Kreml aufgenommen und der kein Müll auf
der Website des camels kann man sich das
Video noch mal angucken und man kann
hier noch mal nach genau das ist nur ein
kurzer Schnitzel aber es geht ja im
kalten Rücken runter wenn man das sieht
wir schon einmal kurz rein
sie haben selbst ein Kind adoptiert aus
Mario Polen nicht wahr ja Herr Präsident
ihn ein kleines nein erst 15 Jahre alt
jetzt weiß ich was es heißt Mutter eines
Kindes aus dem Don das zu sein es ist
schwierig aber wir leben uns das ist das
Wichtigste das ist wahr ich denke wir
werden alles schaffen nicht wahr ja
natürlich
der Internationale Gerichtshof wird
vermutlich dieses Video auch als
Beweisstück auswerten es ist nämlich
unglaublich schwierig natürlich das zu
beweisen dass Putin und wolverbalover
persönlich dafür verantwortlich sind
dass diese Kinder verschleppt werden und
dann russifiziert werden sozusagen das
ist eben eines der Beweisstücke wie auch
die vielen anderen Propaganda Videos
teilt auch sehr viel dieses dieser Junge
den sie da angesprochen hat der
15-Jährige Jugendliche sie zeigt ihn
dann auch auf dem persönlichen telegram
Kanal und zeigt wie wie stolz er sei
dass er jetzt den russischen Pass
beispielsweise bekommen habe also mehr
oder weniger spielen die sich selbst
oder schießen die sich selbst ins Bein
in dem die so viel teilen weil dann
nämlich natürlich auch die persönliche
Verantwortung klar wird aber für die
eigene Propaganda scheint zu
funktionieren es gibt eine Szene auch
die mit gruselig kleines Mädchen im
Stadion
können Sie das einmal kurz einordnen wir
werden das gleich sehen was passiert da
ukrainische Kinder die in Russland
landen und dann auch von von Familien
dort aufgenommen werden werden teilweise
auf Bühnen vor sehr vielen Menschen
teilweise nur im kleinen Raum als
Propaganda Mittel benutzt müssen dann
eben hier dieses eine Mädchen wird wie
wir im Video glaube ich gleich sehen
werden ein Militär umarmen man die
müssen sich ukrainisches Mädchen das
sozusagen sich jetzt dankbar zeigen soll
dafür dass es endlich gerettet worden
ist ganz genau wir hören einmal kurz
rein
danke
annetta kluges Mädchen sei nicht
schüchtern sprich wir sind bei dir wir
sind in deiner Nähe
vielen Dank Onkel Juri dass du mich und
meine Schwester und Hunderttausende von
Kindern aus Mario Paul gerettet hast
ich habe es ein bisschen vergessen
an Jutta sei nicht schüchtern du kannst
zu ihm hingehen und ihn umarmen kommt
Kinder wir nehmen uns alle in den Arm
hier ist der der euch gerettet hat ihr
kotname ist nicht umsonst Engel stimmt's
Juwelier niederwich sie haben das Wort
was das verkommen also möchte von Onkel
Juri nicht gerettet werden definitiv
nicht wer ist das und diese Kinder die
wir da sehen sind alles ukrainische
Kinder
sehr häufig ich war ich war ja in der
Stadt balakia sechs Wochen nach deren
Befreiung die war sechs Monate lang
unter russische Besatzung und auch dort
im Rathaus wird in eine Liste gefunden
mit Kindern die nach Russland geschickt
wurden ich habe dann gefragt was sind
das für Kinder und das waren eben auch
Kinder sehr häufig von Familien die
nicht so viel Geld hatten den dann
erzählt wurde ach die haben besseres
Leben die müssen dann dort nicht mehr im
Kriegsgebiet Leben und und den Kindern
wird besser gehen so dass die Eltern
sich dann irgendwann wahrscheinlich nach
ja nach sehr lang sehr lange sehr viel
Druck auch dazu einverstanden
damit die Kinder dann dorthin gebracht
werden und jetzt
finden die die Kinder nicht mehr und
suchen diese Kinder bereuen natürlich
die Entscheidung die Kinder weggeben zu
haben sehr häufigsten Kinder eben
ausweisen Häusern Kinder die dann Eltern
ja keine keine guten Möglichkeiten
hatten in diesem Sinne von Onkel Juri
sie sagen 16.000 ungefähr man kann die
Zeit schneller momentan haben die
ukrainischen Behörden sind so bei 19.000
20.000 es gibt auch zahlen die viel
höher liegen es gibt zahlen die bisschen
weiter drunter liegen es ist sehr schwer
einzuschätzen und ich glaube wir werden
das erst Jahre nachdem diese Krieg
beendet ist wirklich erfahren können
gibt noch einen anderen
Propaganda Filme über versteckte Kinder
wenn einmal kurz rein
soweit wir wissen leben heute etwa 800
Kinder ohne Eltern interniert wir müssen
uns besonders um diese Kinder kümmern
und ihnen Aufmerksamkeit schenken wir
werden den Familien so gut wie möglich
helfen es gibt einen staatliches
Programm und monatliche Zahlungen
und natürlich die Schule den
Kindergarten alles was ein Kind
glücklich macht
es ist klar dass jedes von ihnen eine
schwere Tragödie erlebt hat aber wir
müssen zusammenhalten und Solidarität
sein
[Musik]
ich möchte den Eltern danken die die
Kinder aufgenommen haben ihnen Wärme und
Liebe geben ich war in einigen heim und
habe die Hingabe gesehen mit der sie die
Kinder erziehen
und jetzt stehe ich hier und begreife
dass ich diese Kinder in zwei Monaten so
dramatisch verändert haben es ist
einfach fantastisch
das sind alles Kinder die entweder
Waisenkinder sind oder aber Eltern haben
oder sind ukrainische älter bei den
Weisen Kindern muss man noch dazu sagen
dass viele der Kinder die in Location
weisenhäuser lebten tatsächlich noch
leibliche Eltern haben die sich aber
nicht so gut um sie kümmern konnten so
dass Sie auch wirklich die Möglichkeit
hätten sie ihren Eltern zurückzukehren
ähm ja also sind wenn man von weißen
Kindern spricht dann sind das ganz ganz
wenige die wirklich weisen Kinder sind
die dort leben also sehr viele haben
leibliche Eltern oder andere für solche
berechtigte
sie sagten vorhin es ist psychologische
Kriegsführung die daraus stattfindet
ich glaube da geht's auch tatsächlich
auch um diesen demografischen Faktor die
auch die russische Bevölkerung schrumpft
an Sie die Frage sie haben einen sehr
eine sehr klare Position was
Waffenlieferungen die Ukraine zum
Beispiel angeht und ich finde man kann
die haben das ist völlig legitim das
auch zu sagen nichts desto weniger wenn
Sie das sehen dann wird er mehr klar mit
wem man es da eigentlich zu tun hat dann
wird dann doch auch klar dass da jemand
auf der anderen Seite ist der
offenkundig von nichts zurückschreckt
und zu absolut allem bereit ist würden
Sie sagen mit dem sollten wir trotzdem
versuchen irgendwie zu sprechen auch
wenn er nicht will und das mit den
Waffenlieferungen lieber sein lassen
also erstmal läuft es mir da auch kalt
in Rücken runter ich habe sowieso
verkrieg und für Verschleppung von
Menschen gar kein Verständnis
hat keiner oder haben weniger für alle
Fälle aber wenn es keiner hätte wird es
ja auch keine Kriege geben
ich glaube wir suchen alle nach Lösungen
wie wir diesen Krieg beenden können oder
wie diese Krieg beendet werden kann und
natürlich weiß ich dass die Frage der
Waffenlieferungen hoch umstritten ist
aber wir sehen ja jetzt schon dass es
jetzt sowas wie ist ein schreckliches
Wort eigentlich
abnutzungskrieg gibt ja also um wenige
Meter oder Kilometer Gelände gewähren
werden tausende von Leuten praktisch
getötet der auch die Soldaten die
russischen Soldaten werden ja als
Kanonenfutter
eingefüllen uns irgendwie zurückversetzt
in den Ersten Weltkrieg ja und es muss
Lösungen geben wie wir Druck auf
Russland ausüben in Verhandlungen
einzutreten wir können ja nicht sagen
wir warten bis Putin nicht mehr ist also
wir können nicht noch zehn Jahre warten
man muss immer mit den verhandeln die da
sind auch wenn sie schreckliche Dinge
machen wenn man das verweigert wird es
ja heißen man kann erst verhandeln wenn
Putin Weg ist
schon Vorschläge gemacht man muss ja
immer sagen wie entsteht
druckverhandlungen zu führen die
Chinesen können zum Beispiel Druck auf
Putin ausüben haben sie nicht gemacht
doch machen Sie also das fand ich im
übrigen wirklich nicht ganz seriös wie
mit dem chinesischen Vorschlag
umgegangen wurde der der Folge gesagt
hat die
territoriale Integrität der Ukraine
bleibt da war nicht besonders viel für
die Russen drin
und ich meine wir haben immer den
Vorschlag gemacht Indien Russland jetzt
Lula hat sich Angeboten müssen
vermittlerrollen einnehmen jetzt hat der
Herr Ischinger der ja durchaus für
Waffenlieferungen ist und war
Militarisierung gesagt die
Bundesregierung muss sich auf
verhandlungsszenarien vorbereiten auch
die Hälfte der Bevölkerung bei uns sagt
es wird zu wenig dafür getan
Verhandlungen
vorzubereiten ob die zum Erfolg führen
weiß niemand aber man muss es versuchen
man muss diesen Krieg beenden sonst geht
er Jahre und die Leidtragenden sind die
Bevölkerung in der Ukraine also ich
meine
Folter mordverschleppung sind
direkte Folgen eines schrecklichen
Krieges und denn der muss beendet werden
niemand hat hier praktisch die Welt
vorne ihr das machen kann aber wir haben
zu wenig gemacht um die
verhandlungsoptionen in gang zu
wenn Sie das Argument hören was
antworten Sie sie sagt mir eben man
müsse Druck auf Russland ausüben aber
wenn sie sie persönlich haben auch die
Waffenlieferungen interessiert wenn Sie
das kritisieren dann üben sie Druck auf
die Ukraine aus nicht auf Russland in
diesen Moment denn gerade gibt es keine
Grundlage für Verhandlungen da die mir
Putin das sehen wir obwohl er diese
große Winteroffensive angekündigt hat
die dann im Endeffekt nicht wirklich
erfolgreich war geht davon aus dass er
militärisch gewinnen kann in der Ukraine
momentan ist die Front
verhärtet bewegt sich nicht stark aber
die Ukraine bereiten eine Gegend
Offensive vor und wollen dann wieder
Gebiete zurück erobern ja und jetzt
jetzt sofort dann Waffenlieferungen
einzustellen fällt damit fällt man den
Ukraine in den Rücken damit irgendwann
kein Druck auf Russland aus
etwas anders
machen sie würden sagen lass uns das
lassen keine Panzer keine Panzerhaubitze
keine Waffen keine Option diese
Waffenlieferung den Krieg extrem
verlängert haben und ihn weiter
verlängern das heißt die würden das
Einstellen ich würde das Einstellen nach
anderen Wegen suchen ich meine wir sagen
man muss ein bisschen sagen die die bei
uns extrem diese Waffenlieferungen
befürworten Anton Hofreiter oder
Zimmermann die sagen die Ukraine Musiken
was heißt denn dass die Ukraine Siegen
also man muss politische Ziele
definieren wie man diesen Kriegen
einstellen was bedeutet das was bedeutet
das für die Ukraine das bedeutet dass
dieser Staat bald nicht mehr existieren
wird glaube ich nicht dass das ist so
und das ist das ist kann ich in
Deutschland
das wissen wir ja alle nicht also wir
wissen
was glauben Sie denn was passieren würde
wenn wir diese Waffenlieferungen
einstellen was passiert wenn wir so
weitermachen
ich sage nicht einfach einstellen
sondern sag einstellen unten wegzufinden
wie Friedensverhandlungen aufgenommen
werden können mit jemandem der das nicht
wissen aus dieser militärischen Logik
austreten also beide Seiten sagen jetzt
wir müssen siegen
was klar Siegen ist ist nicht definiert
von beiden Seiten das ist kein gutes
Moment
schlechtes Argument weil sie machen ein
semantischen Trick sie sagen Hofreiter
und andere sagen die müssen Siegen ja
genau ganz ehrlich ist es nicht komplett
wumpe um es mal sozusagen ob man sagt
die müssen siegen oder die dürfen nicht
verlieren das ist doch in der Sache das
ist völlig egal das ist nicht ganz egal
doch in der Sache ist es egal na ja es
geht um die Frage es geht um die Frage
würden sie jetzt sagen nehmen wir
Verhandlungen auf bleiben wir mal in
ihrer Logik oder auch ja dann müssen wir
jetzt so lange Waffen liefern bis
praktisch Russland in dem militärische
Defensive Situation kommt und durch die
durch die die Kriegs Resultate gezwungen
wird praktisch Verhandlungen aufzunehmen
weil Russland merkt ich kann die Ukraine
militärisch nicht besiegen
wahrscheinlich ist das die bittere
Wahrheit ist das würden Sie sagen aber
was passiert mir eigentlich wenn das
nicht passiert sondern wenn Russland
militärisch gewinnt kann er trotzdem
sein trotz Waffenlieferungen kann sein
dass Russland militärisch gewinnt sie
werden auf alle Fälle nicht verlieren
also da bin ich mir sicher dort zu ist
das viel zu überlegen und was sagen sie
dazu dass es große Risiken gibt dass es
Atomkrieg geben kann das immer mehr
Länder in diesen Krieg reingezogen
werden kann es sind schwere Antworten
die wo bleiben die
diplomatischen Bemühungen das würde ich
mal gerne wissen von dieser Regierung
von der Europäischen Union wo sind die
wissen Sie was mich immer wundere wenn
ich Menschen wie ihnen Zuhörer an dem
Punkt noch mal geht nicht gegen sie
persönlich ne geht nur um das Argument
aber ich frage mich immer warum stellen
Sie diese Frage nicht der anderen Seite
warum fragen sie nicht Putin wo seine
diplomatischen bleiben also ich habe gar
kein Verständnis warum warum sagen Sie
Chinesen davor gelegt haben war
hilfreich das steht unter anderem drin
die legitimen Sicherheits aller in
Länder Sicherheitsinteressen aller
Länder müssen ernst genommen werden
damit meint er Russland
das Papier der Chinesen ja natürlich
also wenn sie vermittelt die sagen wir
müssen rational bleiben alle Seiten
sollen Zurückhaltung üben und so weiter
also da ist doch da ist doch nicht
ernsthafter geworden müssen Sie
natürlich also das ist ja sagen wir mal
die Herausforderung Diplomatie zu sagen
welche Interessen liegen dem zugrunde
also wenn sie den Krieg beenden wollen
werden sie nicht praktisch ich meine wir
haben auch einen Antrag im Bundestag
gestellt wurde gesagt haben alle
russischen Truppen müssen sich
zurückziehen ja es ist völlig klar
nicht belohnen darf sie können uns nicht
in die Ecke
stellen dass wir irgendwelche Sympathien
hätten mit dem was er Putin macht ich
sage ja auf Putin muss Druck auf
ausgeübt werden wer kann Druck ausüben
China kann Druck aus dem
wirtschaftlichen und diplomatischen wir
können auch wirtschaftlichen Druck
ausüben deswegen war ich immer für
wirtschaftliche Sanktionen gegen den
militärischindustriellen Komplex aber
nicht verwaffenlieferungen
wenn wir hier den Eindruck vermitteln
würden dass die der Stopp der
Lieferungen der Waffenlieferungen ein
schnellen Frieden bringen würde das ist
nämlich nicht so denn wladimir Putin hat
sein Ziel klar definiert und würde in
einem Moment der Schwester das wäre ja
jetzt momentan ein Angebot der
Verhandlungen von ukrainischen Seite
würde er diese dieses ganze Land
einnehmen das ist das ist klar und es
gibt keine keine Grundlage auch in der
Konfliktforschung gibt es keine
Grundlage dafür sagen zu können das
jetzt Waffen ein Stopp von
Waffenlieferungen zu einem schnellen
Frieden führen wird aber die hat auch
die
chinesischen
parteiche von
Präsidenten eingeladen ja also
sie Moskau verlassen hat als Vladimir
Putin wieder Angriffe auf auf die ganze
Ukraine starten lassen das ist passiert